and i'll be your moderator so with us
today we have anita and minister of
national defense
uh
ministers
go ahead
ukraine's capital kiev is on their
threat under siege
explosions are being felt as many seek
refuge
in subway stations
babies are being born
in underground shelters while ukrainians
from all walks of life are banding
together to fight for their freedom
for
the right to choose their own future
russia has tried to make a mockery of
our international system to force a
reversion to a might mix right world
we will not make this happen
in addition to putin's attempt to
subjugate the free will of a sovereign
nation by invading ukraine he has sought
to sow division and discord amongst the
alliance
this was a grave
miscalculation
we are united more united
than ever before
this morning the g7 foreign ministers
met
we were joined by your our ukrainian
counterpart
inspired by the courage and resolve of
the ukrainian people
we are working together to suffocate the
russian regime
we are working in locksteps measures
that were described as a last resort
just days ago are now moving forward
with consensus
the russian regime is being hit from all
angles with severe costs for their
unjustified and unprovoked attack of
ukraine
they will feel the impacts of their
actions financially and politically
immediately
and for years to come
the russian regime and those who have
enabled this crisis are increasingly
isolated soon
there will be nowhere left
for them to hide
putin's attempt to subjugate the free
will of a sovereign nation by invading
ukraine he has sought to sow division
and discord among the alliances
this was a grave miscalculation
we are united and more
measures that were described as a last
resort just days ago are now moving
forward with consensus
the russian regime
isolated and soon there will be nowhere
for them left to hide allies are working
together to equip ukraine with the tools
they need to continue the fight
we hear their call for more help and
we're doing our part
this week the deputy prime minister of
ukraine asked me directly for more
equipment to keep their fighters safe
they need helmets body armor gas mask
and night vision gear
i assured her
canada would deliver
and i meant it
today we are announcing that canada
will send an additional 25 million
dollars worth of this protective
equipment to ukraine and let me be clear
we will send more
to ensure this equipment makes it to
ukraine as soon as possible i've also
worked with my polish counterpart to
secure transportation routes to their
border
to ukraine
together with my colleague minister of
defense and specialists in times of
procurement we will make sure
it gets there
body armor gas masks
worth of
to ensure this equipment makes it to
ukraine as soon as possible
i have also worked with my polish
counterparts
we will make sure it gets there
i'd like to finish by addressing
canadians who have family and friends in
russia
please
tell them what is happening in ukraine
send them pictures videos of what you
and we are all seeing through our own
media and social media
the russian regime has a very powerful
propaganda machine
and that machine is selling falsehoods
and lies about their motivation and
invasion of ukraine
the russian people do not deserve to be
at war with their neighbors family and
friends in ukraine
we all deserve to live in peace and this
madness
needs
annexation of crimea in 2014 and the
occupation of eastern ukraine by putin
we've been on the ground to help ukraine
defend its sovereignty and territorial
integrity through a multi-faceted and
comprehensive approach including by
reinforcing nato's eastern flank
and today i am here to provide you with
a brief update on our response to these
for their strong resistance against
putin's naked aggression
in light of ukraine's evolving needs and
our commitment to continue to support
ukraine in coordination with allies and
partners we have now authorized the
provision of an additional 25 million
dollars worth of non-lethal aid to our
friends in ukraine
as la minister julie uh this aid
includes helmets body armor night vision
goggles and gas masks this aid was
requested by ukraine and we are working
as quickly as possible to get it there
as ukraine continues its fight to exist
we have also approved today
additional airlift support facilitated
by the canadian armed forces
the first aircraft will depart for
europe tomorrow and the intent is for it
to be used by nato and in support of the
delivery of this aid
this assistance builds on the ongoing
work of our canadian armed forces and
the communication security establishment
this support is multifaceted and is as
follows
first our caf is working with the
communication securities establishment
to provide ukraine with expert
in cyber security including cyber threat
intelligence to help ukraine defend its
networks against cyber attacks that are
increasingly forming part of modern day
warfare
i want to reassure canadians that we do
have the tools to keep canadians and
canada's own cyber environment secure
and that i will remain in close contract
with the chief of the cse hle bruce
second we must remember that our
canadian armed forces have helped to
prepare more than 33 000 ukrainian
soldiers for the very circumstances that
we are witnessing now through our
training mission in ukraine
and to those asking whether canada will
send troops to fight in ukraine
a combat mission is not on the table at
this time
nor is it on the table for our allies
including the united states in fact i
had again a productive call on thursday
with my american counterpart secretary
austin
the build-up of troops in europe is to
enhance the deterrence on which the nato
alliance is built
we are always conscious that article 5
of the washington treaty is the golden
rule that an attack on one is an attack
on all
as we have previously stated our caf
personnel previously in ukraine are in
poland and safe and are now preparing to
ensure that we
are ready to support with humanitarian
efforts when required
third the over seven million dollars
worth of lethal aid for ukraine has also
now been delivered in full and in time
to be effective
and lastly we are reinforcing our
support for nato's eastern plank by
expanding operation reassurance which
will further deter russian aggression
and mainstability in the region
i spoke this morning with the ministers
of defense of latvia lithuania
estonia
and france
all of whom expressed their strong
appreciation of canada's ongoing efforts
to reinforce nato's eastern plank and
the alliance's deterrence efforts more
broadly
there are also remains across all
branches of the service 3 400 calf
personnel
who are ready to be deployed to the nato
response force if called upon
the world has undoubtedly become a more
dangerous place
while these dangers can sometimes seem
far away to canadians
our insularity is eroding as
geopolitical fractures caused by the
likes of
so chaos and uncertainty
through these tumultuous times
we must unite as a country and redouble
our efforts to support our allies and
trusted international partners
i will remain in close contact with our
partners and allies
including minister reznikov
with whom i continue to speak each and
every day i will also remain in close
contact with our chief of defense staff
and chief of the cse as this horrific
unconscionable situation unfolds
to ensure
that we are doing our part to help
ukraine defend its nation
despite the horrendous and cruel nature
of putin's war it is heartwarming to see
our allies standing in unison
in defense of democracy
to come together with an unwavering
unity of purpose
merci beaucoup thank you
thank you ministers we will now turn to
questions um so as i said we have 20
minutes just a reminder to uh try to
mute yourself between your question and
your follow-up
thank you very much perhaps the first
question can be for minister or not you
mentioned keeping canadians safe from
cyberattacks
what reassurances can you offer given
russia's announcement this morning of
its nuclear deterrent being
put into place i guess
okay hi rafi let me take that question
in two parts first let me address the
second part of your question relating to
nuclear
i would like to take this opportunity to
denounce the bellicose and irresponsible
rhetoric
of mr putin canada stands united with
allies in face of his naked aggression
and
the
rhetoric relating to
nuclear
capability
that we heard the morning
is highly irresponsible
and we denounce it wholeheartedly in
terms of your question relating to cyber
attacks
and the threat posed to canada
i would like to indicate that since 2019
we have had in place
the authorities legislatively to allow
the communication security establishment
with the tools it needs to protect
canada and canadians
let's be clear that cyber attacks are
part of the russian playbook
and bolstering our cyber security
and safeguarding our critical
infrastructure is critical it is top of
mind and it is the main priority that i
discuss with our chief of the cse shelly
bruce most recently on february 24th
the cse will share valuable cyber threat
information with canadian critical
infrastructure partners and it has on
numerous occasions
issued warnings to canadian
organizations and businesses for them to
take all cautions relating to uh cyber
attacks and cyber security threats
thank you
okay thanks very much and minister
joliet i can ask you you were talking
about the propaganda machine uh that
russia uses so
what are the challenges for canada in
banning the network russia today from
canadian airwaves as the minister
rodriguez suggests that he would like to
do
well there's uh so i'll take also your
question in two parts so the first one
is
obviously we know that right now
russian people are under
a lot of uh miss and under a very
important disinformation
misinformation campaign
and therefore we need
as a country but also the entire west to
be able to send images send information
about what's going on in ukraine
to russia
in russian
and so
it is important for canadians
to be able
to talk to their friends and families to
that would be in russia
to make sure that they understand what's
going on
this is
one of the first time in her history
that
a very important war is happening on
social media and on facebook
and bit by bit
there are protests happening
in russia
because people are understanding
what is going on due to
a bit of information they're gathering
we need to make sure that that flow of
information
is even
more bolstered and so that's why i call
on canadians
on the question of disinformation
here at home and in the west nrt
definitely we want to make sure that rt
uh be taken care of that's exactly why
again this morning i had a conversation
with the minister of heritage pablo
rodriguez and i know he's working on
this as we speak and we all agree that
rt is a problem and that we
will solve it
but i think that
it is a question of rt on our
broadcasting side which pablo rodriguez
is taking care of but it's also rt and
sputnik and all the other misinformation
disinformation campaigns that are going
on made by the russian regime online
and that obviously
we're looking at
making sure that our social media
companies do more to prevent
any form of disinformation by these
websites and by these different entities
through their own networks
good afternoon
negotiations that are supposed to happen
between russia and ukraine
i agree with diplomacy i think that's a
good thing i think that dialogue is a
good thing too but the problem right now
and uh what concerns this means is that
there is a great difference
between what russia has said over the
past weeks and what how it is
at the borders
ukrainian counterpart who was also there
this morning
let's see
i would like to say that i'm extremely
concerned
and in the meantime i would like to
commend all the efforts of ukrainians to
defend their country
the fact that there are certain
ukrainian cities that are completely
surrounded by russian troops
that is a problem with supply lines of
medication and so
ukraine now sometimes it is more
difficult than through poland but they
are still uh
possible entry points thank you liberty
canadian press
yes thank you this question is for
minister jolie uh earlier today on uh at
least one of the political uh television
shows you described uh uh russian
president vladimir putin as um i believe
uh irrational i'm wondering if that was
just a slip of the tongue or if you
actually and you and the government
believe that and if that if you do
believe that if that is the case how do
you negotiate with somebody like that
and how worried should canadians be
about a nuclear war
well nobody that decides to bombard a
sovereign nation such as ukraine can be
rational in doing so
so we all agree that there is a level of
irrationality to what is happening in
the decision-making that president putin
is doing and while doing so he's not
only isolating his nation but also will
affect the his very own people because
there is clearly a um a very strong push
on the part of
of the uk the eu
the united states and us and more and
more countries around the world to to
send a very clear message
to to putin
so
like i mentioned in french lee i'm very
preoccupied with
how
russia has not only decided to
i'm very preoccupied with the fact that
there's been a delta a difference
between
what russia has said over the past weeks
and how they've act
and so in that sense any form of
diplomatic talks
is preoccupying we right right now and
i'm not the only one in the world
because clearly the trust in the russian
regime is is is pretty much at zero at
this point so i mentioned that to my uh
ukrainian counterpart
i was not the only one to
to be preoccupied by that
but at the same time
we need to continue to deliver
goods and aid
maybe lethal and non-lethal to
ukrainians as they're under siege and as
they're fighting for their freedom
and
my follow-up is to minister anand um you
know with this talk about uh russian
nuclear forces being put at a state of
high readiness norad officials have been
warning for years about the need for
norad modernization the head of norad in
december uh during a visit to ottawa
said he was awaiting political direction
from both you and the secretary of
defense in the united states on a
political framework can you provide an
update on where we're at with norad
modernization has that political
direction been given
so thanks for the question i am
going to say that the norad
modernization
piece is
extremely important
to me and to our government
and in particular
we are going to continue to make
critical major investments in personnel
equipment and infrastructure that will
support continental defense
and enhance
our capabilities to respond to emerging
security challenges including in
canada's north
i have had a number of conversations
with my counterpart
secretary of defense austin about norad
modernization
and
these include making significant
investments to the north warning system
in fact we recently awarded a 592
million dollar contract to inuit owned
nasitak corporation for the operation
and maintenance of the north warning
system the bottom line is that we will
remain firm and unwavering in defending
canada's sovereignty the peoples and
communities of the north and our
national interests and norad
modernization is a central aspect of
this prioritization
thank you
mike
global
thank you very much
um clearly ukane ukraine is in need of
munitions and gear and as you've
announced uh canada is now sending 25
million dollars worth of gear um russia
for obvious reasons i would imagine
would not want that gear to arrive in
ukraine as it won't want any guns or
ammunition to come from any other
country countries
i know that you're flying it in not into
directly into ukraine and going over the
border but
now that you've announced it and russia
knows it's coming
do you not suppose that russia will do
everything they can
not to allow it to get into the hands of
the ukrainians
thank you mike
anita and i won't speculate as to what
are the intentions of russia
but what we can tell you both is that
it is important for canada to step up
and to help um and not only that i would
say uh we're not the only ones in in the
world doing so today the eu announced
that they would be providing lethal aid
and that's their first time in their own
history
and so in that sense
we want to make sure that we look at all
options possible to deliver lethal aid
yes we're working with poland but we're
having many conversations with many
countries to make sure that the delivery
is possible
go ahead anita
okay thanks um first of all let's be
clear only putin knows what putin will
do and we will work as hard as we can to
deliver
this aid as quickly and as prudently as
possible
we were successful
in delivering
our first package and our second package
of lethal aid on the ground in ukraine
and we have the logistics expertise
and the relationships with our allies to
ensure
that we are secure when we are
delivering our aid
so i will say that this particular
package today which is 25 million
dollars of
non-lethal aid
is going to in the first instance be
transported to europe
via
hercules
and the canadian armed forces will be
assisting
we will continue to make sure that we
are taking all precautions so that our
aid
reaches ukraine safely and securely and
gets into the hands of the people that
need it
thank you
thank you and my follow-up question is
about belarus which has been home to um
some russian armaments and they've been
launching rockets into ukraine from
belarus and there's been reports that
belarus is now getting ready to uh enter
this fight and enter the war does that
change anything
um for canada and for
canada's allies in terms of
how in terms of the response towards
this uh this conflict
if i
may know that belarus has been uh
facilitating uh russian troops through
their borders for
uh some time and and we know that the
belarus regime has been an issue that's
why this summer we sanctioned president
yuka yuka chenko directly and that's why
this week on friday we announced 50 more
sanctions against belarus
and we will continue to put maximum
pressure on belarus this is clearly
clearly a priority for us but not only
us i would say the entire
g7 and the alliance because we know that
uh belarus and
the russian regimes are working
hand in hand against ukraine right now
and so in that sense uh we will continue
to impose maximum pressure on belarus as
we're doing with
against russia as well
stephen chase globe and bail
hi good afternoon can you hear me
yes we can can you hear me
okay thank you my question is for
minister anan
and the question is the first question
is
the um
ukrainian government to mr zielinski has
called on foreigners to join the fight
against russia and ukraine they're going
to be forming a foreign legion of
volunteers
and the british foreign secretary liz
trust said she would support
brighton's going abroad britain is going
abroad to help this fight so i have the
same question for you um minister anand
uh would you support canadians joining
this ukrainian foreign legion to fight
russia
um would you counsel them against it
what would your position be on that
i will
uh respond initially and then ask my
colleague melanie if she would like to
add anything
but we have advised canadians not to
travel to ukraine for security reasons
we understand this is a fight for
ukraine's motherland and we understand
the desire
to go
but our responsibility as a government
is to indicate the security risks with
undertaking travel to ukraine we are
doing our part to support while keeping
canadians and
canadian armed forces personnel safe
mal
thanks anita um well obviously
a couple of things we've said to uh
people in ukraine since february 1st to
leave ukraine we've also said
to people in canada not to go to ukraine
because of security reasons that has
been a travel advisory for now some time
at the same time we understand that uh
people of ukrainian descent uh
want to uh
s
to support their uh fellow uh ukrainians
and and also
that there's a desire to uh defend the
motherland in that sense it's their own
individual
decisions but
let me be clear we are all very
supportive
of any form of uh
of of support of
uh
to to ukrainians right now that's why
today we're announcing non-lethal aid
body armor night gear
very important equipment and that's why
also we need to do more and we know that
we will be doing more in the coming days
okay it sounds like you're saying it's
up to them if they want to travel over
there
and my second question is
regarding just clarifying the prospects
for and this is from uh obviously
minister anand but obviously i would
like to hear from minister jolie if she
wants to respond as well just want to
clarify the prospect for more weapons to
ukraine are you
shutting the door to more weapons for
ukraine including for instance
anti-tank weapons or are you preparing
or looking for opportunities to send
more
weapons to ukraine
okay uh thanks steve
let's start off by saying here that at
this time
any support we can give to ukraine is
helpful to their military and we
continue to assess daily what we can
provide to the ukrainian people as
melanie just said your question related
to additional
lethal aid and i do support a
multi-faceted approach to the
examination of what aid will be provided
and indeed minister resnikoff and i have
on a number of occasions discussed
the types of aid that would be useful
for the ukrainian army
additional lethal aid is not off the
table we are working with our allies at
the current time to determine who can
provide what and how fast and as those
discussions
ensue we will have more clarity about
what we can do from a canadian
perspective
thank you
now
thank you
well
i just mentioned it in another question
steve um
you saw today the unl's for the first
time in their history the importance the
fact that they would be sending
neutolate
uh as a group
um and so we're doing that uh that
they've done that uh we know that we've
already sent the delayed there's been
two shipments of the delay that were
sent successfully because of the great
work of caf members
and at the same time we know that we
need to do more because
keefe is under threat ukraine is clearly
under siege and that's why we will
coordinate with allies
as we're looking at different options
like anita just mentioned
um
so it seems that we are are all out of
time i was wondering ministers there's
uh two people that would like to ask
questions uh so i was thinking maybe
they could split a question and
the follow-up if you have a few minutes
more um that would be great do you agree
and so ryan and uh uh pallek could
no actually i think ryan left oh he's
still there
uh so ryan maybe you can start and then
uh pollock you could get the uh the
follow-up thank you ministers
yeah um this question's from mr julie
you talked uh in your opening statement
about
encouraging canadians with russian
family to send images
uh to russia of what is really happening
on the ground in ukraine
you know i'm wondering with some of your
language are you hoping to see more than
just uh russian troops back in russia
but also maybe some sort of political
change or regime change in russia as
well
thank you ryan for your question
first and foremost
we need to put maximum pressure
on the russian regime
the entire
g7 members can do so and we've are doing
so politically economically and we're
supporting ukraine through different
means including legal aid
but at the same time it is important
that people in russia understand what is
going on
and also we're seeing protests happening
in moscow in saint petersburg in many
cities across russia this is
an incredible
um
it's an incredible sign of courage
by these own
protesters because we know that
protesting in russia
is something that is
condemned by the regime
in that sense
we want to see
that russians are aware
that that the protesters
are protesting based on information
facts and basically the true reality
that is happening south of the border
that is also why it is important for
canada to have an ambassador in russia
it is important for canada to know what
is going on on the ground and to hear
what are the different
movements of population that are
happening in russia
and so that would be my answer to your
question
lastly manga
hi ministers thanks for sticking around
um i just had a question for mr anand
you said that some equipment has already
landed on ukrainian soil to quote be
effective um can you just sort of
explain how you can be assured that it
is being effective
what the benchmark you're using to say
that is
you know is it merely that it's landed
there as per your timelines or or that
it was physically in the hands of
ukrainian people and just moving forward
how do you measure its effectiveness
or its impact if not in helping with
deterrence
okay thank you for the question
so
we have trained approximately 33 000
ukrainian soldiers
since 2015
and in
delivering bulls lethal non-lethal aid
that aid was received
by the canadian armed forces on the
ground in ukraine
prior to the further invasion by russia
last
thursday
and
the canadian armed forces were able to
hand over the aid to the ukrainian
soldiers
and to assist them and explain to them
what this aid was and would be used for
and so
let's be clear that the work that we
have done as a country and as the
canadian armed forces to build the
relationships
with the ukrainian army
has been fundamental to the transfer of
both lethal and non-lethal aid
and what we
have done
is to extend operation unifier for
another three years
and while that operation is suspended
temporarily we very much hope that it
will
continue
so that we will be able to provide the
ukrainian army with the training
that we have been
providing over the past seven years
so in direct answer to your question how
can i be sure
because the canadian armed forces who
were on the ground in ukraine
told me that they had delivered that aid
and it had been received and i trust
what they say to me
thanks everyone have a good day
thank you so much thank you
bye